You just hit six years,
your anniversary.
Congratulations, and the show.
-We did.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sure the same question
people like me get asked,
you get asked, "It probably
feels a little bit longer
than six years after everything
that's happened."
-It feels
like my entire lifetime.
-Yeah.
-It really does.
I mean,
particularly the last few years.
Every week is a year.
-Yeah.
I think that's about right.
-Someone the other day --
Today, we were
having a segment meeting,
and someone's like,
"When the Mueller came --
When the Barr report came out,
you know, Barr letter
came out 10 days ago,"
I was like, "Stop it."
-Yeah.
It was only 10 days ago.
-And what's been nice
is you have found time
to talk about other things,
and you hosted a town hall
with Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
-Yeah.
-It was about
the Green New Deal.
And I think, you know, again,
something that
on the surface,
people have heard a lot about
but maybe
not much more than that.
-Yeah. It's funny.
It's become this --
instantly became this, like,
cartoonish villain
for the right.
I mean, Trump TV talks about it,
like, all of the time.
-Yeah.
-But very few were people --
People talking
about the politics.
They were talking about
the criticism.
Very few people were talking
about it on its own terms,
which is not to say like,
"Oh, this is the way to go."
It's just, "What is the thing?
How would it work?
What's the theory behind it?"
So, we wanted to kind of
take some time to talk about it.
-And did you find being in
a townhall format
you got the sense that there
are people out there
now more than ever
who accept climate change
as a serious issue?
-I think -- It is one of the
biggest generational divides
in American politics.
I mean, we did this thing,
it was great.
It was like 900 people.
It was in the Bronx, which is
where Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is from.
It's from where I'm from.
We did it in the hospital
I was born in, actually.
-Wow.
-Funnily enough.
-So, now it's getting creepy.
-Yeah.
In the L&D wing,
which was weird for everyone.
-No, we did it there.
And one of the things
I think you've seen that's been
transformational,
particularly in the last
three to five years is,
there's just grassroots energy
around this issue.
And for a long time,
it was like,
"Oh, this thing that's happening
off in the future,
and we should
do something about it."
But there are people
who understand
that we are on
the front edge of it now,
and we have to meet
the challenge now.
-I certainly enjoyed it.
Some people did not.
You mentioned -- or, you alluded
to the fact that, you know,
the Green New Deal is --
Fox News has certainly framed it
as being very problematic.
And they do seem to have
an obsession with AOC
as a creator of bad things.
-Yes.
-Tucker Carlson, though,
focused on you.
-He did.
-And had this to say about you
in the townhall.
-Chris Hayes
is what every man would be
if feminists ever achieved
absolute power in this country.
Apologetic, bespectacled,
and deeply, deeply concerned
about global warming
and the patriarchal systems
that cause it.
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
Of all the things, the idea --
-Bespectacled!
-Yes.
-The idea that
if the feminists take over,
we're all gonna
have to wear glasses?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
It's true.
The most macho thing you can do
is drive your car
without your glasses.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That is --
That is peak masculinity.
-Also, I don't know anything
about Tucker Carlson,
but he looks like a guy
who needs glasses
'cause it's constantly like...
[ Laughter ]
Maybe he'd be, like,
a little -- maybe that's it.
We think he's like,
"Why is he so flummoxed?"
It's like, he can barely
read the cue cards.
-He needs the feminist
takeover to happen sooner.
I think that he did not quite
recognize the context
of that comment
outside the confines
of the bubble of Fox News.
-Right.
That it would escape and be --
yeah.
-It did escape.
And it led to, basically,
the best 24 hours
of social media of my life.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's really nice.
-It's like my birthday.
I was like, "Oh, thanks."
-And you're active
on social media,
and you have War on Dad Bod.
And I know a lot of dads
out there, me included --
-Yeah, we're --
-We just think it's great
that you're out there
fighting the dad bod.
And, so, this is your Instagram.
Do you want to read that
for us right there?
-"Every quarter the femnarcist
junta requires all adult males
to present themselves
for a fitness inspection.
Failure to pass
results in summary execution."
[ Laughter ]
-That was --
I mean, I will say all things --
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
All things being equal, a zinger
from Tucker Carlson to you
is actually a lot more fun
than a lot of the stuff
that comes out of Fox.
You know, I wish it was all --
-Oh, yeah. No.
It was delightful.
-All zingers like that.
-Exactly, yes.
Very low-stakes situation.
-Yeah. That was --
You know, if they were just
going after you
instead immigrants,
I'd be like,
"I'll take that trade, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
But do you have time
to consume much Fox News?
-No, I don't.
I mean, you do see
things across your feed.
You know, we have this thing
where it's on.
You know, it's on in the office.
You got the three
big cable news stations,
and you sort of see
what's on air on CNN,
partly as a sort of
point of comparison --
What are people covering?
What are the general stories
that are driving that day?
I will watch stuff online
sometimes.
I don't have
a huge appetite for it.
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
-But I do end up
seeing a fair amount.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
And do you have a sense that --
Are you surprised
by what you see or is it now --
have you come --
I mean, does it stop being
surprising at some point?
-No. You know what?
What's sort of fascinating
about it, it's like,
it is to news what like
a Broadway set
is to an actual apartment.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
You look at it, and you're like,
"That looks -- That kind of --
That sort of looks like --
That sort of looks like news."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's, like, this fabricated
ersatz version of it.
-Yeah.
-And everyone sort of
does all the stuff
inside the playacting set
that is this little sort of
universe they've created.
And so it's sort of unnerving
and it's surreal.
And I think, to the degree
that people exist inside
just that world,
it could be really toxic.
-Yes. I think we've found out
that that is truth.
-I would also say --
Very true.
[ Laughter ]
It's the oranges
of a lot of our problems.
-Yeah. It really is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a callback.
That's a guest doing a callback.